- Because of the
work that I've done
on these issues protecting
women and girls,
I have heard from people
about scholarships,
academic competitions, I've
heard about job promotions.
We have even had cases
in women's prisons
and domestic abuse shelters
where someone presents
and says they're a female
or they identify as female.
So you are so correct on this.
It is something that
is becoming an issue
in so many different
areas of our society.
And people want to
make certain that
what they have fought
for, the rights,
the opportunities they
have fought for as a woman,
that those are recognized
and that they are
not disadvantaged.
(mellow music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is the senior US Senator
from the great
state of Tennessee,
and somebody who actually
knows what a woman is.
How wild.
Senator Marsha Blackburn,
welcome to the Rubin Report.
- It is good to be with you.
Thank you.
- So I wanna start right there.
You know what a woman is,
and not only do you
know what a woman is,
you've asked other people,
in this case then
Supreme Court nominee
Ketanji Brown Jackson.
You asked her what a woman
was a couple months back
in a very viral clip.
So I want to throw to that
and get your thoughts.
- Can you provide a
definition for the word woman?
- Can I provide a definition?
No.
- [Marsha] Mm-hm, yeah.
- I can't.
- [Marsha] You can't?
- Not in this context.
I'm not a biologist.
- So you believe the meaning
of the word woman is so unclear
and controversial that you
can't give me a definition.
- Senator, in my
work as a judge,
what I do is I address disputes.
If there's a dispute
about a definition,
people make arguments and I
look at the law and I decide.
So I'm not...
- The fact that you can't
give me a straight answer
about something as
fundamental as what a woman is
underscores the
dangers of the kind
of progressive education
that we are hearing about.
- Well, senator, did you
expect that sort of response?
- You know, I did not.
And when you look at the
full line of questioning,
I started with the school
board she serves on
and the fact that they have a
woke kindergarten curriculum,
did she support that?
She said she didn't
know about it.
So I asked her about Virginia
and VMI and that case made it
to the Supreme Court,
US versus Virginia.
And that is the decision
that was written
by Ruth Bader Ginsburg
that allowed women
into our military academies,
and it's kind of law
school first year.
So I asked if she
agreed with Ginsburg
and her writing and gave
her that quote and said
it basically said women and
men have enduring differences.
Well, she said she
had never heard
of the case and was
unfamiliar with the writing.
I didn't think that
sounded quite right.
So I asked her to
define the word woman
and she refused to
do so, as we've seen.
And I did that because
I was trying to get
to men in women's sports and
the impact that is having
on young women, and just
like US versus Virginia,
I know that at some point
what the NCAA has done
with allowing men in women's
sports, there will be lawsuits
and that will make its
way to the Supreme Court.
So I wanted to see
where she was on it.
And Dave, you know
the interesting thing,
I met privately with her
before we did our hearings.
I laid out for her
when we met privately
what I was going to ask
her about when we did go
into the hearing.
We had a delightful discussion.
We met for about an hour.
We went through a
series of things
and I was very fair pointing
out what I was going to ask.
Then when we did our
opening statements
on Monday prior to the
hearing beginning on Tuesday,
I again went
through a recitation
listing the things I
was going to discuss
with her in the
committee setting.
So she knew what was coming
but she chose not to
give me an answer.
And everyone knows that there
are differences between men
and women, and I think everybody
could give me a definition
of a woman, an adult
female, two X chromosomes.
I think that there are plenty
of ways that this
could be answered,
saying, "I am a woman."
There are ways to answer that.
So it just shows you how
far the left is pushing
even members of the US
Supreme Court to deny
that there are differences
between male and female.
- You know, I hate to play
the identity politics game,
but for you as a female
senator asking this question,
how concerned are you now
that as these cases rise up
to the Supreme Court
that they will not
have a foundational
definition of woman?
And as you say, I mean,
we already have it.
We will have men beating
women in collegiate swimming,
in wrestling, in basketball,
et cetera, et cetera.
And although it's just in
some sense, people think,
"Oh, well, that's
just about sports."
It's actually about something
much bigger happening
in society right now.
- Well, it is, and because
of the work that I've done
on these issues protecting
women and girls, I have heard
from people about scholarships,
academic competitions.
I've heard about job promotions.
We have even had cases
in women's prisons
and domestic abuse shelters
where someone presents
and says they're a female
or they identify as female.
So you are so correct on this.
It is something that
is becoming an issue
in so many different
areas of our society.
And people want to
make certain that
what they have fought
for, the rights,
the opportunities they
have fought for as a woman,
that those are recognized
and that they are
not disadvantaged.
So we're going to continue
to stay on this issue
and continue to support
women and girls as they work
to preserve the opportunities
that should be there for them.
- One more on this and then
we'll get to some other stuff.
Do your colleagues
on the other side of
this issue, you know,
generally Democrats consider
themselves feminists,
so that means that they would
be for women in some sense.
Do any of them when you
talk to them privately, say,
"Boy, we've really
kind of lost the ball
on this one and we're
actually defending men who
purport to be women, let's say,
but it's sort of gone too far."
The whole party has
gone so radical,
there's not much
that they can do.
- You know, one of
the interesting things
to me has been how women on
the left will all fall in line
behind whatever the left says
is their agenda for women.
And they stay very
close to that.
They're very submissive to
the left's agenda on gender.
But when you have
conservative women
or women that are center right
or to the right,
what do you hear?
They will come at you and
will absolutely blast you
and say, "Oh, you're
not a real woman.
Oh, you're not defending women."
If you don't fall
in line and submit
to that agenda to the left.
It is a very interesting
dynamic that is happening.
And these leftist groups,
they don't show up
to protect women who
are conservative.
- So I saw you a
couple weeks ago.
You were kind enough
to take a few minutes
in your office right
after the midterms.
And obviously the red
wave did not fully form
the way a lot of people thought.
And when we were chatting
they were still
trying to figure out
even if the Republicans
were gonna get Congress,
which obviously did happen.
Are you hopeful now
that there's gonna be
some actual change here?
I mean, I think a lot of people,
and I know this from
my own audience,
they're happy that the
Republicans got Congress
but there's always this
feeling like, ah, they got it,
but are they gonna
actually do anything?
- And one of the frustrations
for so many Tennesseans
that I talked to
is that you have Republicans
who will not back
Republican principles and
they want them to focus
on getting the government
spending under control,
securing that southern
border, making certain
that crime is addressed,
that we work to get drugs
off the street and
support law enforcement.
Those are the things
that people are wanting
to see addressed.
And they're very concerned
that you will have
some Republicans in
the House and some
in the Senate that won't
support getting things done
for the American people.
I fully believe
that this next two years
is a great opportunity
for Republicans to
show what we are for
and to draw that distinction
between what Democrats are for
and what Republicans are for.
It's a great opportunity for us.
We should embrace that
and we should be bold.
- So, are you hopeful that
the Congress will do it?
Obviously, you don't have as
much leverage in the Senate,
but do you think that
whoever ends up as the leader
and whatever direction they
go will be the right one?
- My hope is that you're
going to see House Republicans
and Senate Republicans
work together to stop a lot
of these bad initiatives
that are coming
out of the White House.
And we need to be sure we
don't make life difficult
for one another, but that
we stay focused on things,
A few things that the American
people want to see done.
The spending, the
crime, the border,
making certain we
fund the military,
making certain that we are
protecting our families.
- Let me ask you a little bit
about your home state of
Tennessee, because Tennessee,
much like Florida, where I am
now, is absolutely booming.
And I told you I
considered Nashville.
It almost happened,
but a lot of my friends
have moved there.
As you know, Daily Wire
has moved down there.
There's really like
a real explosion in
Tennessee right now.
Are you guys just feeling good
about things, like,
we're doing it right?
We're seeing this influx
and it's all good?
- Yes, but bear in mind
this has been a long time
in the making, getting
Tennessee on the right path.
When I was in the State
Senate, there was a big push
and it was a four year
battle, four full years.
We had a governor that was
pushing a state income tax
and I led that opposition.
We kept our state
income tax-free.
We're never going
to have a income tax
in Tennessee because
we've amended
the State Constitution
that doesn't allow it.
- What was the argument for it?
It seems so hard for me as
a former Californian to come
to Florida where I'm
paying no income tax.
The idea that anyone
here would say,
"Yes, we would like
income tax here."
It just sounds so insane.
- Yes, and Tennessee in the
mid '90s had been the test case
for Hillary
Clinton's healthcare,
and it was a program TennCare.
It was to cost $2
billion a year.
But with any
government-run program,
they always underestimate,
they're building it
on theory, and it never
works, never works.
And it was an $8
billion program.
So after that five years of
experimentation, they decided,
"Oh, wait a minute.
We've gotta have money
to pay for this thing.
Oh, we don't have an income tax.
Let's do an income tax
and pay for this program."
Well, as you know,
working on symptoms is not
always the right thing to do.
You have to go to the root
cause, and the root cause
was the program did not work,
and passing an income tax
was not going to fix
the broken program.
But Dave, you know, it
was really wonderful.
People of the state
supported me in that effort
to fight that tax.
It's the people of the state
of Tennessee who stood up,
they stood with me, and we
were able to defeat that tax.
And Tennessee is better for it.
We are a well-managed state.
We are considered one
of the top one or two,
three well-managed
states in the country.
We have the lowest tax burden.
We have our Secretary of State
in the state was
recently honored.
Our state is number one
in election integrity.
Those are things that
people want to see.
So when you've got that
great quality of life,
a well-run state, low
cost of doing business,
a good standard of
living, that's where
people want to come.
- Does it shock you,
the stark difference now
between a well-run state
and a poorly-run state?
I mean, I can always
bring everything back
to California, but you know,
the fact that you have to show
an ID to vote in
Tennessee or in Florida
and you don't in California,
I mean, are you shocked
that they're just continuing
to go down that path,
ballot harvesting,
et cetera, et cetera?
You guys closed your polls
and I think you had results
basically immediately.
- Yeah, that's right.
And when you talk about
poor management of states
I always think, I was listening
to something on
California the other day.
They're going to increase
their state income tax
and they're trying
to pass a bill
that if you leave California
and you've built your
business there, for 10 years
they're going to tax you.
And it reminded me of that
great country song written
by James Dean Hicks.
It's called "The
Hole" and the gist
of the song is when you're in
a hole, stop digging. (laughs)
And so, you know, Dave,
some of these states
need to learn that lesson,
whether they're New York
or Illinois or California
or Washington State.
Just give it up, give it up
and try to start fixing the
problems that are affecting you.
- Unfortunately, they really
like that shovel, apparently.
- Yes, they do.
- And they just keep digging.
What kind of stresses do you
guys have with such an influx?
Do you know how many
people have come
to Tennessee over the
last two or three years?
I mean, my guess is it's gotta
be at least 100,000, right?
- Well, the number
continues to grow
and I think in the Nashville
area they are changing
about 1,000 driver's license
and car tags every single week.
- [Dave] Wow.
- And it doesn't matter where
I go, whether it's to church
or the grocery store or one
of the kids' activities,
I'm meeting people who
have relocated to Tennessee
from California and from New
York and many other places.
Some of these big blue
states, Connecticut, Illinois.
And they say, "You
know, we've just had it.
We can't handle it anymore."
I was talking with
someone from New York
and they said they
left New York City.
They're in the financial
service sector.
We've had a couple of
big relocations coming
out of New York
City to Nashville.
And they said they
have small children
and they thought, "You know,
we can work from anywhere."
And they had started,
here's what did it.
They were trying
to get their child
into a preschool and they
were told by somebody,
"Well, you need to hire a
consultant to coach your child
to get into a preschool
because there are so
few good preschools
that are available that are
not into the woke kindergarten,
woke education,
things of that nature.
So, this family said
after they heard all of that,
they said, "We need to move."
(laughs) And so they
came to Tennessee.
- Have you guys done anything
like Governor
DeSantis is doing here
in Florida related to making
sure that the woke stuff
doesn't get into the schools?
- Oh, yes, yeah.
- And isn't in all
of our institutions?
Yeah.
- Yes.
Tennessee has passed a ban.
They don't allow
the teaching of CRT.
They've changed people that
are on the Textbook Commission.
They go through a
different review process.
They will not allow the woke
curriculums to take place.
They are dealing when they
go back in in January.
My understanding is
they are going to deal
with some of the
gender dysphoria issues
and the way that is
represented to minors,
and the allowance,
what has been the allowance
by some of surgeries
or medications that deal with
the gender dysphoria issues.
- What are you planning
related to covid
if they start quote-unquote
bringing Covid back
or if there's a surge
and all this stuff?
You know, we're hearing
that LA, it's like always
a half inch away from
bringing back masks.
I mean, what can you
guys do to ensure
that Tennesseans can
live the way they wish
and make choices for themselves?
- Well, and we know
that fearful people
are easier to control.
That was one of the reasons
that you had pushing
the lockdowns
and the mandates during
Covid, and you have some,
as Dr. Fauci is being
ushered out the door
he is very defiantly saying
we may have to go back to
lockdowns and mandates.
And I think people are
saying, we're over that.
The science didn't support that.
They are looking at
the learning loss
and the mental health
issues of children
from the masking and the
lockdowns and the isolations.
And they're also looking
at people who have
the vulnerabilities
and are more susceptible to
covid or any other type disease.
And Dave, I think that whenever
the next pandemic comes
that people will be
smarter about this.
And interestingly enough,
they're probably going to be
less trustful of government
and what government
is telling them
and what we're finding
out from the Twitter Files
and other things,
you're going to see how
you had elite Democrats
and federal agencies and
people working together
on what they classified
as disinformation
and what they allowed to
be put out as information.
And now what is it that
we are finding out?
It's probably flipped.
The things that they were saying
was disinformation
was actually correct.
- Yeah.
Are you doing anything
on that front?
- Yes, absolutely.
- In terms of holding
the social media
companies responsible.
- Yes, I am the top Republican
on the Consumer Protection
Data Security Bill.
And we are indeed.
We have spent the
last two years working
on social media and governance
and how they protect
individuals and children online,
how they censor
and how they push forward
information, how sometimes
they push forward products
that are fraudulent products.
So we're going to
continue that emphasis.
- I've only got
one more for you.
I'm gonna make it
real easy for you.
I know you're not in the middle
of a reelection
campaign yourself,
but what's your stump speech
for people to be
hopeful for America?
Because I think people
are, between the censorship
and getting post Covid
and just the general state
of sort of political craziness,
I think people are just looking
for a kind of positive message.
That's how I try to
do my show every day.
- Yeah, you know,
when you go back
and you look at our
founding documents,
there is that encouragement
that we the people
should be the people,
and people is with a capital P.
That is the regard with which
our founders held the people
of this country, looking at it
as a country that
is indeed blessed
and endowed by God and
individuals that are endowed
with these inalienable rights.
And it is up to us to exercise
and protect and
defend those rights.
But it requires people
to be the people
to take the responsibility
to hold their
government to account.
And it's so interesting to me.
I think you can push
people so far and then
they're going to say,
"Hey, wait a minute.
We've had it."
And we saw that with the
lockdowns and the mandates
and people saying, "No,
these are my rights.
They're not government
granted anything.
They are my inalienable rights
and I am going to
exercise my right.
And it is up to you
elected officials
to reign in this
federal government."
- Senator, you are a fine
senator and a fine woman.
And I didn't even need to look
at a dictionary to figure
out what that meant.
I appreciate your time
and I hope to see you
maybe at the Ryman
sometime soon.
- Oh, got it.
Any day.
- Great.
- Always.
You are welcome in Tennessee.
Come see us.
- Oh, thank you.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our
politics playlists.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists,
all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.